Cody is in the Ramsey baby-steps
community Dave when you talk about the
for investment types for mutual funds is
that for someone of any age why would a
25 year old have the same investment
strategy as someone that is 55 years old
well it's not really about your age Cody
and you're not really asking a question
you're making a passive-aggressive
statement but I'll address it anyway so
here's the thing how long is the money
going to be invested and what gives it
the best rate of return during that
timeframe so when you're 25 years old
you can invest money and it could be
invested for sixty years when you're 55
years old you can invest money and it
could be invested for 30 years because
when you get to retirement you don't
cash everything out at 65 you simply
start taking an income off of your
investment portfolio whenever you want
to retire whatever age that is and so
from age 65 to age 85 which if you make
it to 65 and you're healthy
statistically you're gonna make it into
your 80s somewhere average death age is
74 for Mayo 76 for female but that
includes infant mortality teenage death
and so on when you make it to 65 but
very high likelihood in America today -
making it to 85 that's a 20-year period
of time you have to outpace the cost of
gasoline and bread and housing and
electricity going up and so you have a
20-year window to invest a 20-year
window to invest has exactly the same
portfolio as a thirty year or a forty
year or a fifty year window to invest
the problem Cody is is that you've been
reading crap out there that is standard
procedure with most financial planners
and that is to move people into bonds
which is a nightmare especially right
now and move them into money markets
when they start getting older that you
need to change your portfolio mix
that magically at 55 years old investing
quits working and so you should make
your money not work nearly as hard and
the premise is is that you shouldn't
take more risk when you get older but
there's two kinds of risk risk of loss
of money and risk of the money not
making anything you put the money in a
fruit jar you didn't lose it but it
ain't making anything doober so you've
got to put the money in something that
outpaces inflation and so just because
something is standardized in the
financial world does not mean that it is
wise as a matter of fact it may mean
it's not wise and so we're not going
that way Cody so it's no if you have 10
to 20 to 30 to 40 years to invest the
four types of mutual funds I'm talking
about are will outperform almost pick
the funds that have outperforming the
SMP will outperform any other mix out
there it's not rocket science it's just
basic investment portfolio analysis but
people fail to do that because they fall
in line like a bunch of lemmings which
are little rats that run off cliffs
together